david bonjour des gilet jaune autour de
vous et surtout un important dispositif
de sécurité qui a été mise en place ce
matin à un dispositif de sécurité
impressionnant on peut le dire à sophie
elle toute la place des libertés droits
de l'homme a été bouclé par icade et par
des barrières installées par les forces
de l'ordre venus tôt ce matin des jeunes
qui sont venus en petit nombre
ici un protester contre les mesures
sanitaires liberticide jugée liberticide
par léa gilet jaune mais également
revendiqué ce qu'ils réclament depuis
maintenant deux ans puisque ça fait que
deux ans que le mouvement est existe
c'est-à-dire la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale et le rich en
toute matière également protesté contre
cette loi de sécurité un global qui
porte atteinte à la liberté d'informer
selon leurs mots on a pu interroger
sophie tissier organisatrice de cette
mobilisation autorisée par la préfecture
de police
elle part 2 elle parle d'un climat de
guerre civile écouter aujourd'hui on
voit que c'est un climat de guerre
civile en fait et moi ce que je ce que
j'ai du mal en fait à comprendre c'est
pourquoi il ya autant d'appels à la
violence pour une mobilisation c'est à
dire que la police provoque par ce
dispositif ultra puissant et en même
temps on voit bien que à chaque à chaque
manifestation organisée fin lancées par
des groupes liés à l'extrême gauche
il ya systématiquement énormément de
casse autour des manifestations
donc la police fait en sorte de
maintenir l'ordre comme ils le peuvent
certes avec des moyens qui sont quand
même assez démesurée et surtout
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est un
appel massif de une unification
d'énormément de gens pour dénoncer cette
loi sur la sécurité globale qui va
permettre d'amenuiser notre liberté
d'informer puisque cette loi est passée
et c'est vrai qu'il ya aujourd'hui un
climat qui est de plus en plus tendu et
qui est délétère en fait lui une
mobilisation qui se veut tout d'abord
pacifique un vous l'aurez compris mais
les
le dispositif de sécurité a mises en
place par le préfet didier lallement qui
est venu en personne ici à ce matin en
tenue de la tête aux pieds en tenue de
manifestations abris faits les troupes
des forces de l'ordre vraiment instaure
un climat de peur en tout cas c'est ce
que ce qui se fait ressentir ici au
parvis à des libertés et des droits de
l'homme merci beaucoup david de khalifa